sometimes I've noticed when a film's
title is translated into a foreign
language the name gets changed so it
makes more sense to that country's
moviegoers this is true for example when
they release the movie Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs in Israel this is
the United States title okay in Israel
they change the title - and I'm not
kidding it's raining falafel they really
did that that's true that's a true toy
so I have my staff go out and dig up
some foreign film posters so we could
see how they've renamed other movies
it's pretty interesting I thought would
take a look at some of them right now
for example I take the movie Thelma and
Louise okay the United States it was
Thumb and Louise in Afghanistan they
renamed the movie why we don't let our
women drive yeah the movie whiplash the
movie whiplash that's the United States
title the movie whiplash was changed in
Germany too lenient music teacher
they thought he was too soft on a kid
France France thought their audiences
would prefer the movie ant-man if it was
called check this out
solo Daft Punk yeah and then Somalia
okay in America it's Mad Max fury road
but in Somalia it was retitled
uneventful trip to the grocery
okay I was just mentioning Ireland
alright well in Ireland they changed the
name of Amy Schumer's trainwreck in
Ireland it's called
lightweight I have no respect okay we
just had a straight out of Compton
okay Straight Outta Compton big movie
here in the United States well in Canada
they changed it into NWA that was
exceptionally stupid yes in China they
renamed the classic Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory in China they changed
it to five children too old for factory
work
who is right
this shows free Pal might have been
booing the concept of child maybe was
booing a concept yes when we bullet to
your
you took a tough stand there sir when
the artificial intelligence robot movie
ex machina that's what it was called the
United States but when it was released
in Japan it was retitled completely
normal sex partner and finally the
French once again with their what they
went with their translation the
entourage movie is called entourage in
the United States but the French they
decided to call it miss socks to douche
to talk to youth hockey DS that was a
baguette I was eating hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please